yeah so I'm I'm Michael drop boom the
other co-lead author of matplotlib
Thomas kaswell's also here today
everything I'm going to show today works
in version 1.5 which came out two weeks
ago so you can use all this stuff today
so here I just have some imports
matplotlib is alive and well we're
officially an unfocused project now
thank you very much they're managing all
of our sort of nonprofit financial
management stuff we're able to accept
money spend money this is really awesome
we have a lot more developer resources
available then we then we have had
lately so I'm very excited about that
this is our release schedule on october
29th as i said we had a version 1.5 come
out at the end of this year we're going
to put out our version 2 point 0 where
we're changing all the styles
everything's going to look a lot more
modern but anybody who's currently
tweaking their styles and being very
careful with it things may break that's
why we're calling it two point oh but we
are only going to change styles we're
not going to add a ton of other features
so you can kind of continue to live on
1.5 for a little while but you know
we're not going to support that forever
we're not going to repeat a Python 2 to
3-year decade-long transition and then
around the quarter quarter second
quarter of next year we're going to have
2.1 which would again be sort of a
regular feature release I'm not going to
talk about the features that are in
there yet we're still trying to
milestone what what that'll include so
here's some demos all of this working
with 1.5 this is not a new feature but
it's a feature that I think is finally
totally ready for prime time is the
notebook AG back end which is or the web
AG backhand it's a fully interactive way
to use matplotlib in an ID Python
notebook and it works really fast and it
works great ending importantly you have
the same programming model you've always
had in Matt plotless so if you've
written GUI applications that use
matplotlib events in order to fire
things and make things go off all of it
works without any code changes at all
you know
Python notebook so to demo that uh oh
what's I can't see the trace back here
let me let me back out to this okay I
think it didn't register this all right
try this again okay so this is that
interactive notebook thing it's taking
Mouse events if I type keyboard events
you see it's typing out what i'm typing
those are going to the Python kernel and
coming back as new images even really
cool things like matplotlib animation
works just fine in the notebook so
that's all rendering the animation on
the pot in the Python Colonel on the
Python side sending images to the
browser and at a pretty high frame rate
I'm going to close this one because it
eats up a little CPU we have styles
again this isn't new to 1.5 but in 1.5
we've really kind of ramped it up we
have a ton of styles available now so if
you don't like the default matplotlib
style you may not like the one we have
now you may not like the one we choose
for as the defaults for two point oh
it's very easy it's one line of code to
change the style of your plots so to
demo some of that will take this plot
and we're we're using the 538 style here
so that makes your plots sort of look
like the 538 website sorry they're all
cropped on the bottom a little bit there
on what you're saying it's also very
easy you can you can fetch styles over
the internet from an HTTP request so you
might discover a style online that you
want to start using its 11 line to just
use an HTTP request it looks like that's
failing i'm having trouble getting on
the network here but if I were on the
network it would go out and fetch a
style and cash it locally and use it we
now have a lot the
automatic updating is love but it used
to be a mad pallavi plotted something
and then you changed a few properties
sometimes that would update the plot
sometimes it wouldn't we've really kind
of cleaned all that up Thomas did a lot
of that work so if I plot something here
and say I don't like that line style I
want it to be green you really just with
one line everything you just change it
automatically it updates oh sorry I
realize you're not seeing the code I
just ran the code I just ran basically
says line set color green okay and it
makes that change string labels to bar
plots it's sort of embarrassing this
never work till now oh but now if you
you know you can very easily just just
put string labels here these we're using
fun unicode symbols but they can be any
string we have this new thing called a
property cycler so we've always had a
color cycle when you plot a line it
starts as blue then green then read or
whatever the order is now you can do
that with any properties so it can be
colors it can be the dash style it can
be the width anything you can you can
create different cycles of and it will
generate the the you know cross product
of all the different styles so here with
sort of one line I've made a very simple
I don't know why it's doing that it made
a very simple style that might be
suitable for print right so rather than
using colors I'm using dash styles and
it'll automatically choose from the dash
styles each time i plot a new line you
can do fancier things this example again
I'm sorry it's cropped but I'm putting
as as the cycler I'm cycling through
four different color maps and then each
time I plot it will choose a different
color map of note here this this right
here is our new color map by Nathaniel
called veredus which which is their
uniform in
and very you know translates to black
and white very well there's a lot of
research that have gone in this new
color map and into point O it'll be the
default color map so no more jet as the
default which is really pry the worst
default you can imagine uh we have
labeled data support so here I'm loading
a CSV data set of cars and it has their
weight and miles per gallon and various
things in the columns and now with
really just this one line of code we can
pass in a data frame to plot and say we
want to plot miles per gallon versus
wait and use horsepower for the color
and and the number of cylinders for the
size and sorry it keeps going off the
bottom of the screen but with basically
that one line of code you can plot a
data frame in matplotlib really really
conveniently so that's a really kind of
powerful new feature this one's really
brand-new in 1.5 I think there's a lot
of places we want to take this that we
will down the road but the basics are
all there um it's easy when you combine
these sort of cycling and labeling and
all these things something you can do
really powerful things like very easily
plot different data sets against each
other and make a whole matrix of this so
here we've taken a cosine curve and a
sine curve and then plotted them in all
kinds of different permutations all that
kind of happens without very many lines
of code you really don't have to do that
yourself anymore other new features
really quickly we now finally have Auto
wrapping of long text if you just start
writing things that don't fit on the
figure anymore it will create a new line
keep going contour corner masking you
can change you can control whether you
want your empty parts of your data to be
kind of angled or or fill the whole
rectilinear box there the color baller
bars are finally smooth used to be a
problem particularly when you write them
out for PDF you get these sort of thin
little white lines in your color bars
that's been fixed
legend support works automatically from
our different kinds of collections you
know and just sort of a lot of other
things to mention and I'm probably
running short on time yeah I have one
more minutes so as I said to point out
is going to be style changes only 2.1 is
sort of going to be focused on better
interoperability with other projects
that's kind of the the key feature and a
bunch of other features that fit
underneath that it's going to include
our trail its work that's being been
done and we also realize now that Matt
plot lib is a substrate for many other
projects and that's kind of happened
organically we now want to make that
more distinct more more obvious and make
it easier for people to do that kind of
thing so like Seaborn and and other
projects that are using that plot live
they'll have a better time of it so
that's the future and thank you to John
Hunter the original author of matplotlib
and also all of our contributors which
is this huge and amazingly long list so
thanks to all those people and
unfortunately if your name starts with
the lower letter in the alphabet you're
clipped off the bond the screen but okay
thank you I'm Jeffrey Beck I'm the one
of the main Tanner's of pandas and so
i'm going to show you just a quick
retrospective actually and then sort of
what's new ok here we go so we of course
in every version have lots of
enhancements API changes in lots and
lots of bug fixes because we sort of you
know want to create bugs for each so we
can have a next version of course so I'm
just gonna start briefly reviewing some
of the changes in the last this is just
the last year about a year and a half in
May 2014 we at least 14 so I'm just
going to see some of these pretty
quickly just to give you a taste of what
these are mostly features so we have
multi index using slicers in other words
this is just the creation code for this
by the way I just let me go back here
for one second all this is available on
this website so we'll push this up this
is just a repo that I created okay so
you have a standard a multi index frame
both on the index side and the column
side
you want to know how to slice it so this
is how to do it basically we allow you
to relatively easily slice but on both
the levels both on the index and the
column side and you say okay well that's
that's pretty interesting but more
interesting is that you can actually
assign to this and it'll just work and
this was pretty pretty hard to do prior
to this there's actually another way to
do this you can actually use a string
base query which actually goes into the
AST and we can do some interesting
things it actually looks pretty
reasonable for that in the future we're
going to add actually something so you
can do dict like selections so you don't
have to actually specify all the levels
this is a syntax actually borrowed from
x-ray another function we introduced in
14 was called select d types so you have
a lot of different D types and you can
just say here's a lot of different types
and you can say okay just give me a
couple out of that and these are all
good when you change things and I'll
show you that a little bit okay in
version 15 released last about a year
ago just now we introduce categoricals
this was a pseudo d type and these allow
you to basically represent categorical
type date or factor data things like say
you know things that fit in categories
they like male or female things like
that these can get past two other
libraries in a very easy way and these
can be ordered things or unordered the
reason this is useful is then you can
sort by them and have your own orderings
you can do min and Max things like that
that are not lexically ordered they can
be ordered arbitrarily further these
allow a substantial savings in the way
we represent these if you have a lot of
repeated values namely like strings
these allow substantial savings in
memory so here's a typical frame and you
can see this is sees the category column
holds a lot less needs a lot less memory
to represent it okay we also introduced
I'm Delta's in version 15 so you can
represent units of time these are
basically subtractions of dates if you
think about that so these are very
similar to the daytime time Delta in in
the standard library but they're
friendly and their first class in pandas
now
so you can do things like hold them as
you create them as a diff or you know a
shift and you can hold them as first
class objects in pandas data frames or
serious and are various convenience
methods that we provide to allow you to
look at them in sort of an easy way and
convert them to other types of
frequencies ok that was it and the
reason is useful is because then you can
also set them as indexes so just like
you have daytime indexes and we allow
things like resampling well same thing
here so you can use units of time or
they don't to be time they these are
units of reference to whatever point you
want to reference them to ok further we
allow a very convenient access ER so you
now allow the you're allowed to hold
these objects could be day x could be
time Delta's as the actual values of a
say a series and then we allow you to
select in a very relative convenient way
to get properties on these without
actually converting them to an indexing
back so you can you can even do things
like localized dates things like that
and I'll go over this in a bit this is
actually now first class type as well
see Dems with time zones ok and the
reason this is useful is because then
you can actually use these in a very
convenient syntax to example dues
indexing ok virgin 16 which came out
earlier this year so these are actually
i'll say compatibility with the world at
large so read in a standard dataset and
this becomes i've started adopting this
style where we do basically method
chaining and this assigned method it's
kind of like mutate from our and in fact
what it does is this it basically allows
you to in a single statement chain
methods so you can in this case we're
adding a column but we're not touching
the original data ok it's a very similar
it's exactly like this but it allows you
to do it in a convenient way here and
I'll show you why in a second so we can
then do change things where we can
conveniently so here's example so we're
taking the data frame we're doing a
query
then we're signing based upon the prior
statement then we're plotting it and
it's all a nice little convenient
statement looks sequel like I guess and
the reason this is useful is because
then we're going to helps we go sorry so
here this is exactly the same statement
except here I'm actually what i'm doing
is i'm typing this to see born actually
and this is a you can also do this with
map that lib and bouquet soon this
basically allows you to do things like
substitute right directly in and you can
say and it just allows you to put that
everything on the chain even things that
don't directly support it we just pipe
it right to it okay in 16 we also
introduced sample this allows you to
conveniently just select out sample by
how many numbers i want a fraction of
the whole frame this is a row selector
or by percentage sampling here and so
creating say like tests and trained it
is becomes very straightforward to do i
won't go into this we just we also added
a categorical index just like we have
categories so representing repeated data
becomes very efficient and i'll expand
xed thing here okay in 17 we just
released this about a month ago so one
of the big things we did we release the
gill on a lot of operations I have a
little blog post here the idea is of
course that you can use threading to
gain performance and one of the reasons
we did this was a another project called
task allows you to very conveniently so
here's an example this is doing a group
I in in pandas just by doing this you
get performance for free because we
release the gill and this is using
multiple cores on your machine for free
okay we introduced the dot plot accessor
so this we used to have a use to be able
to do you know dot plot and put a kind
in there so we basically allowed
introspection so you can just do this as
an access ur just becomes more
convenient from a syntactical point of
view okay
we introduce we made date times width
times as a first class data type and
this is another so you can now
manipulate these just as efficiently as
regular daytime naive daytime 64's okay
one big API change i'm going to mention
is that for a long time series you had
this this weird thing you had dot sort
which was in place and you had dot order
which was not in place and then four
frames you had that sort which was not
in place so it was really confusing so
we introduced a dot sort values
basically a new keyword to do sorting on
the values and then so now it becomes
every object has sort index or sort
values should hopefully have less
confusion okay now I want to show now
what's in the future so just go to ok so
we have a bunch of things on the plate
for the future potential some more d
types namely like a period or an
interval d-type we're going to add as a
first class d type we're going to add
some support for integer na and we're
going to allow you to in a very easy way
dispatch to numba and to desk so here's
my picture of the future right here so
this is the I i did a graph of this last
time about a year ago and in this
picture it's the same as the other
picture except i have these shaded boxes
and these are potential things that we
could actually dispatch to which would
be a nice thing to be able to do you and
in fact we give this almost for free
pandas will just automatically use them
when they're available the last thing on
a show is a this is going to be actually
in seventeen that one I think this was
just a long time request by some people
or by a lot of people so up till now we
have a rather boring HTML representation
of a data frame so okay still boring
except now we have this new keyword or
this new property called styled and then
you can do things like this this is
using a templating
and then we can do things like this and
this is all chainable that's why I'm
showing this gets more exciting you can
you can multiply chain and you can you
can do subsets here as well then it
becomes even more engine so we have some
built-in methods or that work on the
stolid if this is completely over
rideable actually and then you could do
things like mix and match them this is
an interesting one and then of course
you can do this however a templating
like that this was another I don't know
where you use this but you have this and
last but not least of course you can
hook this up just like any other thing
to an interac would you okay that's it
thanks guys hey everybody can hear me
yes so I'm under a smaller I'm one of
the core developers off so I can learn
and one of the two release managers to
get with you via grisel I want to talk
about what's new and second learning
0-17 that was released last Thursday so
the slides are a bit rough because I had
to do the actual release so there's one
thing that is important a deprecation so
something that will change in a future
netted input on the slides so as you
might know if you work with so I can
learn you have your num by area of data
where each column is the feature in each
temple is a it rose a sample and now
make sure that you always use a 2 D X
should not have any other end them than
to your data if you a lot of people
started passing one of the data and it's
slightly confusing because in some
methods it was using that it features in
some methods it was using it as samples
and it led to a lot of subtle bugs so
always pass to the X anyhow so it's so
everything works as before but we're not
gonna support us anymore in the future
but so now to do actual pulling your
stuff that released Thursday
one is lda which now stands for lighting
directly allocation which is a topic
model using online variational inference
if you're not familiar with static
models this is like on the left you can
see it's like a pansy graphical model
where you assume you have a corpus of
text data usually and you assume there
are some different topics you have a
fixed number of topics usually and you
say each document is a combination of
different topics and each word is drawn
from the distribution for each of these
topics and then you can do some
visualization so not sure if you can
read it on the right here we choose 10
topics and then they're sort of the most
common words for each of these topics
this is the 20 new script data set I
think and you can you hope that these
topics sort of correspond to what is
being talked about in your text this is
very popular model and we now finally
also have a implementation of ethics I
could learn actually this is the fastest
implementation that I'm aware of now
we're slightly faster than Jensen
because we did some more cycling stuff
this is based on the code by Matt
Hoffman and was implemented by chikwe yo
another cool stuff cool thing it we have
now is a new solver for logistic
regression retrogression call SI g so
this is just makes so Jessica regression
in virtual isolation faster if you
choose the solver it's particularly
well-suited for large and very
high-dimensional data so if you use to
SGD classifier before you might want to
use logistic regression or a rich
aggression with SI g sober now it needs
to fit the data into Ram twice if you so
if your data is not gag antic and you
have enough RAM should use their SI g
sober another thing that we change does
actually now a new default homer for
non-negative matrix factorization and
we're going to explain that but so we
had to protect the gradients over before
now we have a coordinate descent solver
and let's see like factor maybe 1.5 to
or up to five times faster than they
also over so not OK matrix factorization
a new version just got much faster in
all cases
another thing that gets much faster is
the tease me manifold learning methods
so that's something method to visualize
high dimensional data I've learned here
my favorite examples of using a digit
status set so this is a completely
unsupervised method it always makes a
lot of very very pretty pictures so here
this model didn't know anything about
the data you just gave it some raw
pixels and you see that it perfectly
grouped different kind of these are
different digits and group them together
in the 2d space so it's very nice method
to visualize high dimensional data and
it got faster in this implementation by
a factor of ten to a hundred sometimes
so a new model lets in there is kind of
a quick helper model if you're familiar
with so I could learn then you probably
know about pipelines so pipelines are a
way to chain multiple transformations of
your data with some classifier and it's
very useful to do a cross-validation
grid searches over a more complex
pipeline it means that you need to write
these transformer objects which is
sometimes like a bit annoying but now
there's this function transformer which
basically creates a transformer object
for you from callable so if you want to
do something very simple well I just do
a lot of rhythm and plus off your data
plus one you can say function
transformer nplog one EP and it just
applies this function so this is an easy
way to go from a function to a second
learn transformer if you just want to
have a static function applied that's
very convenient now the kind of
convenience method that we add is the
voting classifier this is basically done
to build arbitrary ensembles so it just
passes a list of multiple classification
models and so poor student either a hug
voting which means it predicts the class
that was most of most frequently
predicted or soft voting which means it
ever just the probability estimates and
then predicts the most likely class so
this thing is very very popular in kagal
competitions for example
a lot of people use these quoting
classifiers another new classes that got
added were to scaling noodles so these
are for preprocessing one is a robust
scalar that use that kind of subtracts
the median and then scales by the
quartiles so that is more robust than
using the main and assigned deviation in
Amex app scalar which is sort of it
scales down a data by the man / feature
by the maximum absolute value and this
sounds kind of odd but the important
thing is that we wanted to have some
scaling for sparse data and it's very
weird to scale sparse data because you
want to zero to be at the same spot but
you want to limit the range of the data
so this Mac step scalars actually what
you want to use if you want to scale
sparse data and you want to keep the 0
in the same place or something I added
that it's not that grand but it was
asked for really a lot and I hope it's
useful is so this is like the API
documentation you might know from the
reference guide I added this line which
gives you a link to the user guide so
you actually can go back from the guy
document into the user guide which
before you could not do so very brief
they want to talk about what will have
in the future and 0 18 so it has things
that actually in the development branch
so if you check out the development
branch you can have them already one is
a complete rewrite of the Gaussian
processes that adds two things one is
you can do now basically Colonel
engineering so people at Gaussian
processes usually want to create some
crazy kernels here's a possible dataset
from the Gaussian process literature you
want to model this time series and you
can see sort of the Fed points on the
left are the training points and then
you want to like see how this time
series develops in the future and you
have this blue line which is the
prediction and the gray which is the
uncertainty and so if your Gaussian
process expert you might want to write
down a colonel and the colonel let's
actually used here is written down below
so it's a combination of a lot of RBF
kernel
and sinus kernels and rational quadratic
kernels and I don't know what and so we
can now do in secular arbitrary
combinations on kernels and we can also
learn all the parameters of these
kernels efficiently so all the like
fooling point numbers you see there
they're all learned from the data using
data using maximum likelihood on the
data which we can do much more
efficiently the old version of our in
the current version of so I could learn
we use a gradient a non gradient based
methods and then will the new version
you use the gradient based method we
also have been a development version
neural networks it's just very simple
multi-layer perceptrons so there's no
convolutional nets and we don't have GPU
support but you just want to like
compare your random forest your network
you can do this easily and then you get
some like nice filters and mist which is
what you always use with neural networks
obviously in the new book version it
will also be improved cross-validation
what services visible and I messed up
current and future which is also good so
on the right hand side where it says
future this is what it currently looks
like where you have this K fold object
and if you after you instantiate it you
can just iterate over it and you get
training and test set parts for each
split and you have to give say how many
folds another two raters you often need
to say how many data points are there
and if you need to say how many data
points are there you need to know what
the data is in advanced on the left hand
side where it says current this is a new
version where we have the split method
in a split method actually gets the data
and also the labels and so you can more
dynamically generating in ecs based on
what your data actually is this allows
you to nessa cross-validation as shown
here below where you have grid search
and then some inner cross-validation and
some cross walls score that cross
playdates the grid search there is
method cross-validation and so this
probably crashed before sorry because
the number of samples in the inner loop
might change but you need to notice that
number
samples in advance to create a cross
validation object but now this is
possible so this is also in the new
developer version and then a new
development version will also have far
superior so there's sort of a plot of
running time on the x-axis I'm going to
be to the left and explained variance
which is a measure of arrow so you want
to be down and to the left and there's a
comparison blue points are master and
Rec points are blue points are what is
now in release version red points as
will be in the development version and
basically everything went a lot to the
left without getting much worse and so
now pca will be much much faster in the
future and that's it so I'm Brian
Granger and I'm one of the lead
developers of project Jupiter and I
Python and I want to talk to you about
some things we've been up to for the
last six months to a year and then also
talk about some of the things that are
coming up in a new release there's a lot
more than I can talk about in 10 minutes
and I have longer talk tomorrow that
will go into more detail about the
technical aspects the first thing that
we have is a mmm that's you can't see
what I see which is difficult
there we go
nope you can't that's really quite odd
so the first thing we have is a new you
still can't see what I see there we go a
new website we've been working this last
summer with a designer and this is what
the new website looks like although the
aspect ratio that you're seeing well
that looks okay that does not look looks
looks a little odd and compared to the
previous website that we had this is a
abstention substantial improvement we
have a button here you can click this
and I guess I don't have internet i did
i did a second ago but you can try out
the notebook on tribe open org we're
hosting notebooks and docker containers
they're mostly for exploratory purposes
that's being hosted by Rackspace and
there's quite a few kernels that are
running their Python are Julia and
Scylla with spark as well the next thing
that we've been up to is this last
summer we released the first version or
version 40 of ipython and Jupiter and
this was really I won't try to actually
show you anything this was the first
release of the project under the Jupiter
package name and so a lot of you have
probably noticed this if you tried to
update ipython or Jupiter in the last
few months that you will now get Jupiter
packages the Jupiter the notebook is now
under the Jupiter github organization
and packaged so for example the command
line command to run to start the
notebook is now Jupiter space notebook
rather than ipython space notebook
ipython continues to exist as a project
it is now basically the python specific
parts of the project namely the python
colonel i pi widgets and then also i pi
parallel and some other infrastructure
we
earlier in the spring we had been
working with github for quite a while
and they released built into github
itself rendering of notebooks on github
and this is just an example yes please
tell github how much you liked that they
did a lot of work on that and this is a
great example this is the one of the
notebooks in can davidson palin's
excellent book on bayesian methods that
you've probably seen are actually not
not bayesian methods but probabilistic
PI MC stuff governance we have actually
been thinking a lot about governance
aspects of open source and from a
technical perspective this is not
particularly interesting what we're
finding though is that as this community
engages in collaborations with companies
governance becomes very very important
what we have found is that the main
barrier to adoption and contributions
from corporations is not technical
details it's things like governance it's
things that managers and lawyers at
large companies worry about from their
perspective honestly they view
developing new features is fairly cheap
what's expensive is lawsuits and so
governance is the type of thing that
makes their executives and lawyers sleep
well at night and feel good about
contributing to the project we have a
new Jupiter governance repository that
has all the details about how we run the
project and make decisions and I
encourage you to check this out and also
I encourage other projects open source
projects in this space to think about
your own governance it doesn't have to
look like ours but it can be very useful
to have some of this stuff written down
for us this really started just by
writing down what we were already doing
over time it's allowed us to evolve what
we're doing we've also created a new
github organization called Jupiter
incubator we were finding that there was
a lot of interest from the community to
start new sub projects that were a part
of Jupiter but there were still a lot of
a
certainty in questions around those
projects and so we have created a
Jupiter incubator and a very lightweight
process for the community including you
as well as corporations to start new sub
projects that you would eventually like
to become part of the Jupiter project
itself the response has been fantastic
here the existing incubation projects a
number of these has been have been done
by IBM another 1 by bloomberg and
another one by microsoft and then also
kyle Kelly who's one of our core devs
from rackspace is involved in a couple
of these as well so where are we headed
next here is a little bit about our
roadmap I should mention the the last
release that we did for dot oh really
didn't have many new features it was
really focused on us refactoring the
code base and splitting it in two
separate github repos and packages in
practice what that meant was that 40 was
mostly a bug release not a bug-fix
release but a release where we got to
introduce a lot of new bugs and make
your life a little bit miserable we
apologize for that and just thank you
for your patience for dot one of the
notebook should be coming out in the
next month and hopefully we have fixed
all of those new or all of those yet all
of those new bugs and existing bugs and
we have a few new features that i want
to show you quickly here the first is
multi cell selection and actions based
on that so here you can't see what keys
i'm pressing this is j and k or up and
down and then if i hold down shift i can
select multiple cells see will copy
those v will paste those and so you can
so you can do both contiguous selections
so escape clears the selections or you
can go and do dis contiguous selections
so I can delete those cells there's a
number of different actions a lot of the
common actions are wired into this
probably not all of the actions that you
want to use with this are working yet
we're we're we're trying to be a little
bit conservative because that the
semantics around some actions on
multiple cells especially when there's a
discontinuous selection are not
completely obvious but that's one thing
we're very very happy about next is
let's just create a bunch of new cells
copy paste paste so let's say I have a
large notebook and I have a variable
maybe see that's in multiple places in
the notebook and I want to rename that
currently it's really painful to do that
you can press F I want to search for C
replace by D and I'm done all right so
you've got multi-cell find and replace
it you can act do the replacement only
on the selected cells and you can also
do regular expression based searching as
well also the new release will have a
command palette so this is similar to
the command palette in some other text
editors and development environments so
if you do command shift p you get the
following and then i can say unmarked
all cells and this is really useful
because the the notebook has a lot more
actions that are possible then keys on
your keyboard and so we're not able to
bind a key keyboard shortcut for
everything that you'd want to do in this
this command palette gives you actions
to the access to the full set of
commands that are possible on the
notebook one last minor thing it's silly
but I think it's really important and
that is under Colonel there's now a
restart and run all option and in our
minds this is really to address I think
one of the problems we've seen in
usability of the notebook where you
write a notebook and you have some order
of cells and some order that you run
those cells in the colonel
and you save and you send it to someone
they open it up run all the cells that
doesn't work and the reason for that is
that the state of the notebook document
is completely separate from the state of
the colonel and you may have when
authoring the notebook run sells out of
order and so restart kernel and run all
is a fantastic way for you to make sure
that that notebook in its current state
does what you think it does other thing
how am i doing on time one minute left
fantastic we have a lot of new step of
new things coming up so the first thing
so for dot one that I just talked about
should be out in the next month 50 will
be the first of a series of releases
focused on a lot of new front end work
in the notebook in particular 50 is
going to have a prototype of something
we're calling the Jupiter workbench
initially this will be a new page in the
existing notebook web application and
the idea is that it will on a single
page allow you to combine multiple
different components so you could have
for example a to text editors tabbed on
top of each other next to a notebook
above a terminal so things like that the
first release we're targeting to have a
file browser a text editor in a terminal
it will not have the notebook initially
that getting that getting the notebook
into this single page layout is a lot
more work also related to this is that
we are changing how we write and package
our JavaScript code there's a lot of
people who want to take the different
building blocks of the notebook and
reuse them on different web pages today
that is really really painful and in the
future or that the very near future we
will have a lot of independent loosely
coupled NPM packages so here are some of
the new repos that we're doing this work
in so for example if you want to have a
code cell on your web page that can talk
to a colonel you can NPM install Jupiter
j/s services and then probably Jupiter
Jays input area output
area in cells and just use that to throw
a colonel in cells on your page or you
might also want a full notebook on your
webpage and so this is sort of that the
plumbing that we're doing underneath the
new user interface that we're building
in the long run so this is the next plus
to release we will have standalone
output areas in this panel layout system
and also the ability to hook up text
editors to these output areas as well
obviously eventually the notebook will
show up in this environment as well and
there's I encourage you to check out
this roadmap it's under the Jupiter
roadmap or i should say there's a pull
request with this content against the
Jupiter roadmap repo we have a lot of
other exciting things going on in I pie
widgets and trait 'let's and all the
other projects as well so please watch
this space for details on that and I
think I'll stop there thanks